Silver honors go to cars an Cotter
who's film beckus was made at the
Stockholm Academy of Dramatic Arts in
Sweden beca's tells the story of two
young and homeless Kurdish brothers who
decide they are going to live in America
after the film Superman appears in their
local movie theater Wow
III just want to say I'm very proud of
you
all filmmakers because it's very very
difficult to make films and especially
when you're student and what I always
say that the the budget is always unfair
to the talent and it's I think it's for
every director or filmmaker in the
industry and we do it anyway and that
that's what I love about ourselves
filmmakers we do it and the picture we
have in our mind in our head we do it
anyway and I am gonna tell you a little
short short story about why we do it and
we do it anyway when we were shooting
this film we had no money and I needed a
crane for some pictures because it would
look much better
and tell the the scene much better for
me and we have no money for the crane or
and there was no crane in the industry
there so we had a handy guy and I said
Mahmoud can you please make a crane for
us I need it and he did a very simple
crane in one end it was two baskets and
other end it was one chair for the
cameraman and we were on set ensuring
the scene and we had we they kept the
DOP thought said where is the wait for
for the balance and we didn't have it so
we throw so many stones we had to the
baskets and that wasn't enough so I was
lucky I had some extras
and I had like four extras sitting there
in the baskets and we made our pictures
and it looks really really good good and
it brought me to this guy and this is
why I love you guys
we are filmmakers we do it anyway and I
hope the producers see us and give us a
little bit more money all right thank
you